I think executive compensation ought to
be set by the market place boards do
make mistakes sometimes in the executive
compensation process I think there's
been some obvious abuse of executive
compensation in a few cases but I think
the more generic problem is not that
people can be paid well but the
measurement of performance is not right
and I think the two errors that have
been made one a lot of times performance
is measured to linearly it doesn't
include the comprehensive performance
and secondly a lot of times performance
is too short term so i think that boards
should be setting compensation i think
highly performing people are be paid
very well based on market conditions but
i think boards should do a good job and
I think frankly I think our board has
done a good job being sure the
compensation is not just linear and
being sure it covers a long period of
time not just what happens over a short
period
I think that the shareholders have to
select the board members and the board
members have to make those kind of
operating decisions I don't think
shareholders have enough information to
make concrete operating decisions they
could put the board in the position they
simply couldn't attract the kind of
talent that they need to operate we're
seeing that right now is some of the the
interference by the government in any
setting executive compensation I do
think shareholders should be very
careful in selecting the board members I
would say this though I don't think
shareholders have been unduly
particularly institutional shareholders
in what's been going on recently because
a lot of shareholders are very
short-term oriented and so they
encourage short-term performance and
they get executives that act in the
short-term manner so I think if
shareholders want a different long-term
result then they need to invest with a
longer-term perspective and that's a
really important responsibility versus
micromanaging the board process